GO AHEAD AND CALL THIS MEETING
TO ORDER AND WE WILL BE --
WE'LL HAVE TO WITNESSES PER SIDE
WITH A TIME LIMIT OF THREE
MINUTES EACH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WE ASKED TO STATE
THEIR NAME AND ORGANIZATION ONLY.
AND WE WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
WE ARE STARTING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
THE FIRST BILL BEFORE US WILL GO
WITH ACTUAL GO WITH MR GRAYSON
SPILL BECAUSE MISTER RECORDS
MEMBER THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER GRAYSON WHICH I TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
EMERGENCY AIR AMBULANCE SERVICES
ARE AN ESSENTIAL PART OF THE
STATEWIDE EMS SYSTEM.
AND PROVIDE A CRITICAL LINK
BETWEEN RULE AREAS AND URBAN
HOSPITALS.
THEY ALSO PLAY A KEY ROLE IN
DISASTER RESPONSE AND HOMELAND
SECURITY.
IT'S CRITICAL SERVICE PROVIDERS
TRANSPORT ALL EMERGENCY PATIENTS
WITHOUT KNOWING IF THE PATIENT
HAS ANY FORM OF MEDICAL
INSURANCE OR ABILITY TO PAY YET
ALL PATIENTS ARE GIVEN THE SAME
HIGH LEVEL OF CARE.
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY THREE WILL
REPLACE THE MEDI CAL RATE FOR
THESE PROVIDERS TO THE RULE
MEDICARE RATE THE MEDICARE RATES
HAVE NOT BEEN ADJUSTED FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
AND A SUPPLEMENTAL FUND THAT HAS
BEEN -- THAT
IS HOW PROVIDERS IS SET TO
EXPIRE AT THE END OF NEXT YEAR.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ALSO INSTITUTE
A PROHIBITION ON BALANCE BILLING
BY AIR AMBULANCE PROVIDERS BY
OAK FOR PATIENTS WHO ARE INSURED
IN CALIFORNIA.
WE BELIEVE THAT CAREFULLY
CRAFTED LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
WILL ALLOW THE PLANS AND
PROVIDERS TO CONTINUE TO
NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH Y.
REQUIRING THE PATIENT ONLY
REMAIN RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR
ORDINARY OUT OF POCKET EXPENSES.
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY THREE IS
CRUCIAL TO THE FUTURE OF
EMERGENCY AIR AMBULANCE SERVICES
AND THEIR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
LIFESAVING SERVICES TO RESIDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN
AYE VOTE NOW RIGHT TURN IT OVER
TO ME AT THIS BILL.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
KID DO I DO THINK YOU FOR THE
CONFIDENCE IN THIS PRESENTATION --
THAT IS.
AT HIS WONDERFULLY RECEIVED AYE
AYE I DO TURN IT OVER TO CAST
GOT REPRESENTING AIR AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS IN MORE AFTERNOON AYE
CATS GOT RESUMING THE AREA MOST
WRITERS ARE CALIFORNIA I THINK
THE AUTHOR DID A FANTASTIC JOB
PRESENTING THE BILL.
I'M AND TALKING THROUGH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE WORKED HARD
IN THE ASSEMBLY TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS RELATED TO BALANCE
BILLING.
AYE WE THINK WE'VE STRUCK A NICE
BALANCE BOTH WRITERS AND THE
INSURERS --
SINCE THEY'RE NOT OPPOSE THAT'S
A GOOD THING --
AND WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITH THAT WHO WAS STOP WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM NOW MASS MADAM
SECRETARY TAKE THE ROLE WITH
HERE.
BASED HERE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BIGELOW HERE.
WHAT'S UP BURKE.
CAREER [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
THE MOST.
MCCARTY.
LESS AREA [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO BERMAN
WALDRON.
SO HAVE A QUORUM [inaudible]
YEAH.
WAS A SECULAR IS.
BECAUSE THAT JUST EDITORIAL.
WE WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND --
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BETH FELL A BIT HAVE FELT ACCESS
CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT
VIRTUALLY OF THE PROVISIONS
BANNING BALANCE BILLING FOR ERIC
CAN CONSUMERS RELYING ON THEIR
AMBULANCES THANK YOU.
GEN FLORIDA ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT AGAIN PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE OF THE BALANCE BETWEEN
PROVIDE.
NICK LOUISE WAS CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS WE
SUPPORT THE BALANCED BILLING
DOWN AS WELL THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN KNOWN TO BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
C. NEMECHEK CLOSE MISTER.
FREEZE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
VERY GOOD CLUBS --
THAT THE MOTION IS BY MISTER
BIGELOW --
AND THEN THE SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO THE MOTION IS CONCUR IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS AND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES MAYES AYE
ANCHOR CURRY.
AGAR CURRY I BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
BONTA FLORA FLORA I LOVE THEM.
MCCARTY BY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO BERMAN WALDRON.
GIVE NINE VOTES THE BILL IS OUT.
IF YOU VERY MUCH SIR
[inaudible]
MR MCCARTY
.
RIGHT TRUE THOUGH OKAY THANK
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS THAT
TECHNICAL BILL WHICH WOULD HELP
STREAMLINE THE RATE SETTING
PROCESS.
FOR TREATMENT FOR OPIATE
ADDICTION IS A ONE OF A SERIES
OF BILLS IT'S COMMITTEES WORK ON
THIS YEAR DEALING WITH THE OPEN
YET EPIDEMIC --
WITH ME IS THAT DEPARTMENT AS
WELL AS THE OPIOID MEANS
PROVIDERS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MELISSA ROWLAND
I'M HERE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES I'M HAPPY
TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL -- AND
LIKE TO THANK THE SPONSORS AND
TO OF THE AUTHOR FOR I'M
CARRYING THIS MEASURING CREATING
EFFICIENCIES --
WITH THIS PROGRAM.
IT OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SCENE NO ONE AND IT IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NUMBER BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
CNN WE HAVE A SMALL MOTION BY
MISTER A BIGELOW SECOND BY
MISTER FLORA BELIEVE.
THE MOTION IS --
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
WHICH I TO CLOSE MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU I I JUST WANT ALSO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR FOR
WORKING WITH US I KNOW THIS WAS
THAT GOTTEN AMEND IN THE SENATE
TOWARDS THE END THE SESSION AND
IT'S NOT WHITE.
NOT QUITE BLACK WHITE BUT A
GREAT BETWEEN SO THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR HELPING A LITTLE
LONG BUT SO GO AHEAD HAVE MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS DEAD.
TO CONCUR IN SENATE AMENDMENTS
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGAR CURRY AYE BIGELOW AYE
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE AYE
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA I WOULD
MOVE.
WHEN BONE AYE MCCARTY AYE
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN?
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
THURMOND [inaudible]
WALDRON.
THAT'S ELEVEN ZERO YOUR GOES OUT
MR MCCARTY.
AND WE HAVE A COUPLE OF MEMBERS
WHO CAME AND SO WE WILL --
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON ITEM NUMBER.
TWO MISTER GRAYSON SCHOOL.
THAT RIGHT QUICK.
I'M SORRY WITH THE BILL NUMBER
HERE.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWO FIVE NINE THREE SO PLEASE
OPEN THE WRONG CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
MAMA.
LIMON AYE NAZARIAN.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WALDRON.
THAT HAS TWELVE VOTES SO.
AND WILL OPEN WILL GURCHARAN
WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE ROLE --
AND CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON
ITEM NUMBER. ONE ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE FORTY NINE MR MCCARTY
[inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
SANTIAGO THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WALDRON.
SO THAT IS.
TWELVE ZERO AND WE WILL WAIT A
COUPLE MINUTES. TWO MINUTES OF
LIT EXACTLY. FOR OTHER MEMBERS
TO ADD ON
IT APPEARS THE OTHER
MEMBERS WILL NOT BE COMING TO
ADD ON SO THAT WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND CLOSE.
TO CLOSE THE MEETING THANK YOU